c'est officiel la ville de La Verrière
6000 habitants a été choisi pour lancer
la 41e édition de la course cycliste
Paris-Nice le dimanche 5 mars prochain
les coureurs partiront de la
communivelinoise pour 169,4 km direction
la vallée de Chevreuse avant de revenir
vers le Mesnil-Saint-Denis en passant
par la côte des 17 tournants pour la
verrière ce sera une grande première
cette historique en un mot une vraie
fierté une vraie fierté pour la ville
d'accueillir un événement planétaire et
près de 8 millions de téléspectateurs
qu'on les yeux rivés sur la verrière et
puis sur le Mesnil-Saint-Denis puisque
l'étape part de la verrière et arrive au
Mesnil c'est un engouement populaire
c'est une étape sans précédent dont on
est vraiment très très fier le lendemain
le lundi 6 mars et la petite commune de
Bazainville 1500 habitants qui va
accueillir l'épreuve le départ de la
deuxième étape sera donné place
Saint-Nicolas là aussi ce sera une
grande première pour la commune petite
commune très motivée par par l'enjeu et
bien situé aussi c'est dans la pleine
dedans donc encore une fois pas un arbre
pas de rien du tout donc une course qui
risque de partir vite c'est pas très
très connu benzainville mais chacun
verra bien que c'est un de ses charmants
petit village tel qu'on en a dans les
Yvelines et c'est une façon pour nous
aussi de faire découvrir la richesse des
paysages des Yvelines les deux communes
vont accueillir de grands noms sur leur
terre le vainqueur du dernier Tour de
France Yonas Wingard a déjà annoncé sa
présence du côté des Français on attend
David Gaudu romain Bardet ou encore
Arnaud démarre